ADAM MARTIN: And so today and
for the remainder of the week,
the theme is going to be
the cell division cycle.
And so we're going to really
talk about the cell division
cycle in every lecture this week
with the penultimate lecture
talking about how dysregulation
of the cell division cycle
results in a pathological
condition known as cancer.
OK, so here is now a cell
going through the cell division
cycle.
It's entered into
mitosis right now.
And these guys here are the
chromosomes of the cell.
And you're going to see them
line up at the metaphase plate.
And eventually
they'll be segregated
to the two poles of the cell.
And then the cell will
divide along its equator.
OK, so I thought we
could start today
by just thinking about what
has to happen in a cell
during the cell division cycle.
What has to happen during this
process in order for the cell
to replicate?
Yes, Miles?
AUDIENCE: For all
the [INAUDIBLE]
all those have to be duplicated
so that each cell has
a starting number.
ADAM MARTIN: Mmm hmm.
So Miles suggested
the organelles
have to be duplicated such that
the daughter cells can inherit
those organelles.
And that's correct.
What else has to happen?
Anything else have
to be duplicated?
Stephen--
AUDIENCE: DNA has
to be duplicated.
ADAM MARTIN: The DNA, the
nuclear DNA, the chromosomes,
have to be duplicated.
So the chromosomes
have to be duplicated--
duplicated.
What else has to happen
every cell cycle?
What would happen to the size of
the cell just when it divides?
Yeah, Udo?
AUDIENCE: It would grow.
ADAM MARTIN: So Udo is
suggesting that the cell has
to grow, right?
Because if the cell didn't
grow, then cell division
would make smaller and
smaller and smaller cells.
And so another thing the cell
has to do during the cell cycle
at some point, it
has to grow in size.
OK, and what's the final
point of the cell cycle?
What happens?
What's kind of the
goal of the cell cycle?
Yes, Stephen?
AUDIENCE: Undergo mitosis.
ADAM MARTIN: To undergo mitosis.
And so the cell has to
physically divide, right?
The chromosomes have
to be segregated,
and the cell has to
physically divide.
OK, so you can think
of the cell cycle
as the goal of getting
all these events to happen
is to get one cell
to become two cells.
So you need chromosome
segregation.
And you want an equal
segregation of genetic material
into two daughter cells
after the cell divides.
OK, so today, we're going
to unpack the mechanisms
that allow a cell to
do many of these things
and how it's regulated.
And one thing to
think about is, what
is going to determine
whether or not
a cell enters the cell division
cycle and undergoes a division?
What do you think are
some things that cells
would care about if it's
trying to decide whether or not
to divide?
So one thing a cell is going to
care about in a multicellular
setting is whether it's getting
appropriate communications
from other cells that
are telling it to divide.
And remember,
Professor Imperiali
told you about signaling.
And one example was receptor
tyrosine kinase signaling.
And this is just a diagram
showing you the RAS map kinase
pathway.
And one of the effects
of this signaling pathway
is to promote cells to enter
the cell division cycle in order
to divide, OK?
So this is in a
multicellular organism,
the signaling is important.
For unicellular organisms, cells
might care about whether or not
there are nutrients present
or whether or not the cell is
of the right size, OK?
So cells have to
make the decision.
I'm going to focus mainly
on cell communication
and how that might change
the cell physiology.
And I want to start
by just giving you
a little bit of an overview
of the cell division cycle.
So there are four
distinct phases
of the cell division cycle.
And I split them
into two classes.
There are phases where things
physically happen to the cell.
And those are S
phase and M phase.
And so during S phase, S phase
stands for DNA synthesis.
And it's during this phase when
the nuclear DNA is replicated,
OK?
And so for each of the
action phases, if you will,
there's some sort
of machinery that's
involved in changing the cell.
In the case of S
phase, that would
be DNA polymerase and helicases
that mediate the replication.
So helicases, DNA polymerase.
And you remember from
earlier in the semester
when we talked about
DNA replication
all of the proteins
that are involved
in replicating a chromosome.
OK, the other phase where
something really physical
happens is M phase,
which is mitosis.
And during M phase, this is
when the sister chromatids
of each chromosome are
separated to the daughter cells.
OK, so this is when chromosome
segregation happens.
And again, during
this phase, there
has to be some sort
of machine that
gets activated at this phase
of the cell cycle in order
to, in this case, physically
separate the chromosomes
from each other.
And that machine in M phase
is the mitotic spindle,
which you'll recall is a machine
that consists of microtubules.
So these are microtubules.
And in each cell cycle,
these events have to happen.
But they have to
happen in order, right?
You need DNA synthesis before
you segregate the chromosomes,
right?
So there has to be
an order to this.
So these other phases
are called gap phases.
And there are two
of them, G1 and G2.
And events happen
during these gap phases
to help to ensure that things
happen in the right order.
And so in G1, the cell has
to decide whether or not
to enter into the cell cycle.
So some things to consider
here, the one that I mentioned
before is whether or not there
are growth signals present.
OK, so for a metazoan
cell, it's important
that the cell doesn't just
divide without any regard
to what's going on
in the surroundings.
There needs to be a
communication between cells
such that there's the
proper balance of cell
division in a tissue
for specific cell types.
OK, so this G1
phase, this is when
the cell-- if the cell
goes from G1 to S,
this is when the cell
commits to the cell cycle.
So G1 to S, this
is the time when
the cell commits to going
through the entire cell cycle.
So if the cell passes
this G1 to S transition,
then the cell has committed to
going through the entire cell
cycle.
OK, the other phase,
this G2 phase,
ensures that this type
of quality control that
happens, it has to ensure
that the DNA is replicated
before the cell
moves on to mitosis.
So you can think of G2
as a phase where there's
a quality control
mechanism and the cell
cares about whether or not
its DNA is replicated or not.
OK, so now I want to
tell you basically
the answer as to how this system
works in a eukaryotic cell.
And this system requires
a level of control.
And it requires
a control system.
And what this
control system does
is to ensure that these
different events that
happen during a cell cycle
occur in the right order.
OK, so this control system is
going to ensure proper order.
And there are two
main components
to this control system.
The first is called cyclin
dependent kinase, or CDK.
And so cyclin dependent
kinase is a kinase,
so it can post-translationally
modify other proteins
by adding a phosphate
group to them.
And so it's through
that mechanism
that cyclin dependent kinase can
modify events and control when
they happen in the cell cycle.
OK, and the other key
component of the system
is a protein called cyclin.
And what cyclin is is it's the
regulatory subunit of the CDK.
So this is the regulatory
subunit of CDK.
And so without the cyclin,
the cyclin dependent kinase
is inactive, OK?
So the CDK needs the
cyclin to have activity.
So cyclins increase the
activity or activate CDK.
OK, but there are different
flavors of cyclins.
There are actually
many different cyclins,
at least four
classes of cyclins.
And these cyclins appear at
different phases of the cell
cycle and then go away.
OK, so the cyclins oscillate
that's why they're called
cyclins, because
they come on and off.
And depending on which
cyclin is present
determines what CDK is
going to phosphorylate, OK?
So these cyclins also
determine substrate specificity
of the kinase.
So which cyclin determines what
protein the CDK phosphorylates.
So I've outlined three
classes of cyclins here.
Here is a G1S cyclin
in complex of CDK.
And then here's an S cyclin
complex with CDK in red.
And so what do you
think the S cyclin
CDK is going to phosphorylate,
what kind of protein?
Anyone have a guess?
Miles--
AUDIENCE: Helicase.
ADAM MARTIN: Yes, you're
actually exactly right.
It's going to
phosphorylate and activate
things that are involved
in DNA replication.
And Miles is right.
Helicase is one of the proteins
that gets phosphorylated
by S cyclin CDK.
And then similarly, M cyclin
CDK, which appears here
in blue during
mitosis, M cyclin CDK
is going to
phosphorylate proteins
that are involved in
forming the mitotic spindle
so that it induces cell cycle
events that happen specifically
during mitosis.
OK, so you all see it depends
which cyclin is present
that determines what cell cycle
events are happening at a given
time.
And therefore, it's
important that we understand
how these cyclins appear at
distinct cell cycle phases
and whether or not that's the
mechanism for the oscillation.
Yes, miles--
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about [INAUDIBLE] question
about mitosis [INAUDIBLE].
So I know that microtubules make
sure the chromosomes separate
from the cell.
How does a cell
regulate having half
of the organelles on each side
[INAUDIBLE] split [INAUDIBLE]..
ADAM MARTIN: Some
organisms employee motors
such that organelles
are physically sort
of put in daughter cells.
But I think often it's
just random, right?
If you dissolve the
organelle and it
becomes kind of a bunch
of different vesicles,
then if you just split in half,
there's a high probability
that each daughter cell will
get parts of the organelle, OK?
So organelles can
change their morphology
during the division
process in such a way
that they're able to be
inherited by both daughter
cells.
OK, that's an
excellent question.
So it's the cyclins that really
determine what's happening.
And I just wanted
to point out here
that one of the main
transcriptional targets of RTK
signaling is this G1 cyclin, OK?
So it's these
signaling pathways that
lead to the increase
in G1 cyclin
that start the cell on
this process of entering
into the cell cycle, OK?
So you get these cyclins
getting synthesized.
And the cyclins appear
in a defined order.
OK, so there are
different cyclins,
but they appear relative to each
other in a stereotypical order.
So they appear in order.
And it's that
order of the cyclin
that defines which cell
cycle events happen
at what time in a cell.
OK, now I want to tell
you a little bit about how
the machinery that's involved
in the control of the cell cycle
was discovered.
And I'm going to
start by telling you
a little bit about
budding yeast.
And by showing you how
this was discovered,
it will give you a sense as
to how this system controls
the cell division cycle.
You'll recall that
budding yeast can
exist as a haploid
cell in addition
to existing as a diploid cell.
So there's a
haploid/diploid life cycle.
Also, one nice feature
of budding yeast
for this particular
question is that you
can infer the cell cycle
morphology of the yeast
just by looking
at its morphology.
So budding yeast
divides by budding.
And the size of
the bud indicates
what cell cycle phase
the cell is in, OK?
So you can infer
cell cycle phase
by morphology of the yeast cell.
So for example, if
we look up here,
here's an unbudded yeast
cell that's probably in G1.
Here's a yeast cell with
a little teeny bud on it.
That's probably an S phase.
Next to it over here is one
that's a slightly bigger bud.
And here's one with
an even bigger bud.
And that one might
be in G2 phase.
OK, so because this
bud grows in size
over the course
of the cell cycle,
you can just look at
a yeast cell and infer
what the cell cycle phase is.
OK, so I'm going to tell you
about a genetic screen that
was done to look for mutants
that were defective in the cell
division cycle.
And these are known
as cell division
cycle, or CDC, mutants.
Now, what type of yeast cell,
haploid of diploid, might
you want to screen mutants with?
What would be the advantages
of either one or the other?
Yeah, Natalie?
AUDIENCE: Would you do
haploid, because if it's
a recessive mutation
[INAUDIBLE] expressed?
ADAM MARTIN: Yes,
so what Natalie
suggested is to start
with the haploid mutants
because there's only one
copy of each gene such
that if you hit it, now you
no longer have a functional
copy of that gene.
If you started with
a diploid cell,
you'd have two
copies of the gene.
And you'd have to have two
mutations both happening
in the same gene, which
would be a rare event.
OK, so it's better to start
with a haploid in this case.
Now, what's the problem if
you mutate a gene that's
involved in the cell cycle?
What's going to
be the phenotype,
the immediate visible phenotype?
Is it going to be alive or dead?
Carmen--
AUDIENCE: Dead.
ADAM MARTIN: It's going
to be dead, right?
And it's hard to work with
an organism that's dead.
OK, so what was done is to look
for a particular type of mutant
which is known as a
temperature sensitive mutant.
And a temperature
sensitive mutant
is a mutant where
the cell or organism
is alive and well
at one temperature
but dead at another
temperature, OK?
And so the screen basically
involved taking yeast.
Here's yeast growing
in a test tube.
And this is now haploid yeast.
And you can treat that
yeast with a mutagen.
It doesn't matter what,
just something that
will induce mutations at a
high rate in these yeast cells.
And then you can
take these cells
and plate them on media
where individual cells will
grow into colonies.
OK, and if you grow it at
22 degrees C for yeast, this
is the most moderate
temperature you can choose.
So this is what's known as
the permissive temperature.
OK, but you can also take
this plate of used colonies
and duplicate it and grow
it at another temperature.
And you might get
something that looks
like this, where you see this
colony grew at 22 degrees,
but at 37 degrees
C it did not grow.
And that would suggest
that, then, this has
a temperature sensitive mutant.
And this temperature
of 37 degrees
is known as the
restrictive temperature.
OK, so that would identify a
temperature sensitive mutant.
Now, is every temperature
sensitive mutant
that you identify, is that going
to be a cell division cycle
mutant?
Miles, you're
shaking your head no.
Why is that?
Can you explain your logic?
AUDIENCE: So there could be
a couple different proteins
[INAUDIBLE] there's
too many mechanisms
in the cell that could be
dependent on temperature
to narrow down to just
[INAUDIBLE] mutant cell cycle.
For example, if a
phytoprotein mutant organism
would mutate [INAUDIBLE]
temperature sensitive,
without that protein
it would die also.
ADAM MARTIN: Exactly.
So Miles is suggesting
that if you just mutated
any old gene that was involved
in viability for this yeast,
and it unfolded at 37 degrees
because you sort of made
a mutation that
made it unstable,
then you would identify that as
a temperature sensitive mutant.
So what would be a
good criteria, I guess,
that we could use to select just
the mutants that are affecting
the cell division cycle?
Might there be a way
for us to do that?
I guess I'm asking, can we
narrow down the phenotype,
right?
Temperature
sensitivity could be--
by affecting any
process in yeast,
is there a way we can gear
it towards the cell division
cycle?
Diana--
AUDIENCE: Maybe [INAUDIBLE]
specific phase of the cell
cycle, you could look
at the morphology of it.
And if all of them
stop at the same phase,
you might assume
that you [INAUDIBLE]..
ADAM MARTIN: All
right, very good.
So Diana is suggesting is that
we looked for a phenotype.
And she's guessed
that the phenotype,
if this gene is involved in sort
of mediating a change from one
cell cycle to phase to
another, that if you
mutate that, you'd have yeast
that's all stuck in one phase,
OK?
And that's indeed the phenotype
that was screened for.
OK, and so if you just take
a random population of yeast
that's dividing,
you'll see cells
that are unbudded, small
budded, slightly bigger budded.
And if you count the number
of cells, what you'll see
is that most of your
cells are unbudded.
Some are small budded.
And a larger percentage
are large budded.
And this just reflects the
relative amount of time
that yeast is in each of these
phases of the cell cycle.
So yeast spends most
of its time in G1.
Therefore, if you look at a
random population of yeast,
you'll see most of the cells
will be in the unbudded state.
OK, so this is for
wild-type normal yeast.
Now, what was identified is
a cell division cycle mutant,
CDC 28, which at the
restrictive temperature
causes a train wreck at a
specific phase of the cell
cycle.
So all of the cells now are
stuck in the unbudded state.
And so this suggests
that these cells, when
they are shifted to the
restrictive temperature,
are still able to move
through the cell cycle.
But once they get to this
phase, they get stuck.
OK, so here there is a
cell cycle arrest at G1.
And they confirmed it was G1
by measuring the DNA content.
And by measuring
the DNA content,
they were able to show
that these cells did not
duplicate their DNA.
So they didn't even
start to undergo S phase.
They were stuck in G1, OK?
OK, so that suggests that
the CDC 28 gene is required
for cells to go from G1 to Sl.
OK, so the wild-type
CDC 28 gene is
required for this transition
from G1 into the S phase.
And it turns out that this yeast
CDC 28 gene is the one yeast
cyclin dependent kinase, OK?
So this was sort of
the defining mutant
for cyclin dependent kinase.
And you'll recall
earlier in the semester
when we talked about
molecular biology
that we talked about work
done by Paul Nurse who
used functional
complementation to clone
the human cyclin
dependent kinase
by transforming DNA into a
different yeast, fission yeast.
But again, that rescued
the cell cycle arrest.
And that's how the human
cyclin dependent kinase
was discovered.
And I just wanted
to point out here
that the work I'm
telling you about
was awarded the Nobel Prize
in physiology and medicine
in 2001.
And it was awarded to
Leland Hartwell, Tim Hunt,
and Sir Paul Nurse.
Leland Hartwell did
the screen that I just
told you about there
and identified CDC 28.
And we already talked about Paul
Nurse earlier in the semester.
Tim Hunt worked on clams and sea
urchins and identified cyclin.
So this was the
work that identified
the regulatory machinery
of the cell cycle.
And they sort of
showed that this
worked in a number of
different organisms.
And they showed that
it was evolutionarily
conserved from yeast
all the way to humans.
OK, so this is a
conserved mechanism.
OK, so there's a mechanism
that actively governs
the transition from
G1 to S. And I'll
point out this transition
is known as start in yeast.
And it's called the restriction
point in mammalian cells.
It's kind of the point of
no return in the cell cycle.
But the cell cycle
doesn't just blindly
charge through the
rest of the way.
And there are certain
quality control mechanisms
that are in place to
ensure that things happen
in the proper order and that
the quality of events happening
is good before the cell
moves on to the next stage.
And so I'm going to define a
concept called a checkpoint.
And the checkpoint is a type
of quality control mechanism.
And checkpoints operate
in the cell cycle
to ensure that one event
doesn't occur till the preceding
event happens correctly, OK?
So this ensures
proper order of events
and ensures that
events happen correctly
before the next subsequent
event has to occur.
OK, so one example of
this is, if you just
consider S phase and M
phase, DNA replication
has to finish before the cell
starts segregating chromosomes.
Otherwise there's going to
be catastrophic consequences,
such as possibly creating
a cancer cell, OK?
So one example of a checkpoint
is called the DNA damage
checkpoint.
And what the DNA
damage checkpoint does
is it looks to see
if there's DNA damage
or if the DNA is
still replicating.
And if either of these
cases is present in a cell,
then it sends a signal.
And that signal, in order to
influence the cell division
cycle, has to interface with the
cyclin CDK control machinery,
OK?
So this signal will
then inhibit cyclin CDK.
And cyclin CDK governs two major
transitions in the cell cycle.
So there are two major what
I'll call transition points.
There's the G1 to S, which
I just outlined over there,
which is called start.
So there's G1 to S. But
there's also G2 to M, OK?
So these, basically, the
transition out of the gap
phases, those are the
key transition points
that can be
regulated by the cell
to either slow things down
to halt the transition
or just go right through, OK?
So let me tell you
about an experiment that
defined the functionality of
the DNA damage checkpoint.
And I'm going to tell you about
work done by Weinert and Leland
Hartwell.
And it was published in 1988.
And they were interested in
what the nature and the function
of these checkpoints was.
And so you can
take budding yeast.
And you can damage its DNA
by irradiating the cells
with X-rays.
And if you irradiate
the cell with X-rays
in a wild-type normal yeast,
so in the normal yeast that's
not mutant, then
this damages the DNA.
And the cell stays in G2.
OK, so it stays in G2.
OK, and there's a delay.
OK, so here what I'm
drawing is a G2 delay.
So the cell spends an
abnormally longer time in G2
than it normally would if
you didn't damage its DNA.
All right, and then over time it
will continue in the cell cycle
and enter into the
next cell cycle.
And what's interesting about
this is that these cells live.
OK, so one interpretation
from this result
is you damage the cell's DNA.
It delayed the cell cycle in G2.
So it didn't rush right
into chromosome segregation.
And that allowed the cell
time to repair its DNA.
And that enabled the cell
daughters to live, OK?
So that's an interpretation.
Now, part of the evidence
for that interpretation
is that Hartwell and Weinert
discovered a mutant called
RAD 9, so the RAD 9 mutant.
And RAD 9 stands for
radiation sensitive.
This is a radiation
sensitive mutant.
And this particular
radiation sensitive mutant
disrupted the delay.
So it disrupted the
checkpoint here.
So what happens in
a RAD 9 mutant is,
again, you irradiate
cells with X-rays.
The cell goes from
S phase to G2.
But this time, there's no
delay, so it goes from G2,
the poor yeast
charges unsuspectingly
into mitosis with
damaged DNA and divides.
But in this case,
there's a high level
of death in the
resulting progeny.
So here you have death.
OK, so RAD 9, then,
is a gene that
is involved in promoting
the cell cycle delay such
that the yeast cell has
time to repair its DNA.
And if you remove that delay--
so here there's no delay.
If you disrupt this delay, which
defines the checkpoint process,
right?
The checkpoint is a process
whereby if there's DNA damage,
you delay the cell cycle
such that the cell has
time to repair it.
If you don't have that,
it has bad consequences
for the cell and results
in your cells undergoing
premature mitosis before they've
had a chance to repair the DNA.
Let's see.
I'm going to use this one here.
All right, one thing
you might be wondering
is what causes these cyclin
proteins to oscillate.
And so the last
point I want to make
is I want to tell you about
the mechanism that allows
these protein oscillations.
And it involves a
mechanism that's
going to be new
for you, at least
from the context of this class.
It's a mechanism that's
regulated proteolysis.
OK, so there's a regulated
degradation of these cyclin
proteins that allows them
to go up and then down, OK?
So if we consider just one
part of the cell cycle,
well, if I plot the
concentration of cyclin
and we look at M cyclin
from G2 to M phase--
so this here is a time axis--
the M cyclin goes up in M phase.
And then it drops precipitously
during mitosis, specifically
at the metaphase/anaphase OK, so
this is for the mitotic cyclin.
And I'm going to tell you
that this precipitous decline
in cyclin levels is due
to regulated proteolysis.
OK, and it involves a
mechanism that you were briefly
introduced to by
Professor Imperiali,
because it involves a small
protein known as ubiquitin.
What ubiquitin is is it's a
small 76 amino acid protein.
So it's a 76 amino acid protein.
But this protein can get
attached to other proteins.
So it's a post-translational
modification.
OK, so ubiquitin, which
I'll abbreviate UB,
ubiquitin is attached to
lysines on a target protein.
And the attachment of ubiquitins
to lysines of a protein
has important consequences.
And what Professor
Imperiali told
you about is when this
happens in the case of protein
misfolding.
But this ubiquitination
of proteins
also occurs to proteins that
are not denatured or misfolded.
And it's a way of regulating
protein levels in the cell.
OK, so what happens is--
I'll show you a complicated
diagram of what happens.
But I'm really going to focus
on this step right here.
There's a series
of steps that are
needed to get ubiquitin to get
attached to the target protein.
I'm going to ignore
pretty much all of that.
But there is an E2
enzyme that becomes
conjugated with ubiquitin.
And then the ubiquitin is able
to be transferred to a target
protein.
And rather than
make this generic,
I'll let you know the target
protein is going to be cyclin.
So we'll just say cyclin.
And so there's an enzyme
that transfers the ubiquitin
from the E2 to the cyclin, OK?
And it's
polyubiquitinated, meaning
there's a chain of ubiquitins
added to the cyclin.
And it's carried out by a
particular type of enzyme known
as an E3 ubiquitin ligase.
And there are hundreds of these
ubiquitin ligases in humans.
And different E3
ubiquitin ligases
confer different specificities.
So they target
different proteins, OK?
So different E3's target
different proteins.
And so this is where the
specificity comes from, OK?
So when a protein in the
cell, misfolded or not,
is polyubiquitinated
like this, this
is a garbage tag on
that protein, OK?
So you can think of
polyubiquitin as a garbage tag.
And once it's
polyubiquitinated, it's
sent to the proteasome, which
Professor Imperiali showed you.
And this is the structure
that degrades proteins.
OK, so if the protein is
targeted for degradation
by putting this tag on it, it's
going to be rapidly proteolyzed
in the cytoplasm of the cell.
All right, now I want to show
you some experiments that
provided the first evidence that
this regulated proteolysis is
what sort of causes the
cyclin to oscillate, OK?
And it's going to involve
a new model organism.
Is there anyone here
that has ranidaphobia?
OK, we all like frogs?
OK, so this model organism
is xenopus laevis,
or the African clawed frog.
And I want to thank my
colleague at UMass Amherst, Tom
[? Oreska, ?] who provided
the slides of frogs for me.
So what's great
about these frogs,
well, other than
them being very cute,
is that they lay a ton of eggs.
And the eggs are huge, OK?
So here is a mom, a mom frog.
And then you see all these
circular things all around
the frog are the eggs.
OK, so they're about
1 millimeter in size.
They're huge.
You can collect these eggs,
put them in a test tube.
And you can see all
these eggs that you
have in this test tube.
And then you can
spin the test tube.
And by spinning the test
tube in a centrifuge,
you crush the eggs.
And so that results
in this middle layer
here, which is cytoplasm, OK?
And you can remove
it with a syringe.
And what you end up with is
a concentrated cytoplasmic
extract.
So that's all cytoplasm.
OK, so that's a
lot of cytoplasm.
OK, so for the xenopus
system, this system
allows you to get this
highly concentrated--
because it's not diluted.
It's the same concentration
as cytoplasm almost--
cytoplasmic extract, which is
known as xenopus egg extract.
OK, and what's amazing
about this egg extract
is it can go through
the cell cycle
even though it's not in a cell.
OK, so you can get this
extract to essentially simulate
the cell cycle.
OK, so you have to
mimic fertilization,
because that's when cell
divisions start to happen
in the normal frog embryo.
But once you do this, then you
mimic the fertilization process
by adding calcium,
and then you'll
see this extract go
through the cell cycle.
And you can see it by
looking at the morphology
of different structures
in the extract.
So this is a nucleus that
has assembled an extract
around some DNA that was added.
OK, DNA replication can
happen in this nucleus.
Other events that happen in the
interphase of the cell cycle
also happen in this extract.
And if you wait, then
it will go into mitosis.
And you'll start to see
mitotic spindles assembling
in the extract.
OK, so what's important about
this, this is totally in vitro.
OK, so this is an
in vitro system.
There are no cells.
But you're able to see the
extract go through the cell
cycle.
OK, and if you were able to
look at cyclin, like M cyclin,
you'd see that M cyclin levels
go up and then down and up
and down.
They oscillate just like
they would in a cell.
And this is just a
diagram showing you
that here where mitotic
cyclin, M cyclin, concentration
is in blue and CDK activity
for M cyclin CDK is in purple.
So you see it goes up.
And then the cell
enters mitosis.
Early mitosis is in blue.
Late mitosis is an orange.
So you see mitosis happens
when M cyclin is high,
just like it does in a cell.
And then it degrades.
And then it repeats.
OK, so this is all
outside of a cell.
But you're just
looking in a test tube.
And you can recreate
the cell cycle.
Now, this, because this
is a biochemical system,
allowed these researchers--
in this case, the researchers
who did this experiment
were Andrew Murray and
Mark Kirchner at Harvard.
And what they did was to test
the role of various components
in this oscillation.
The first experiment
they did was
to RNase treat the extract
to get rid of all the mRNA.
And if you degrade all of
the mRNA in this extract,
you no longer get the cycling.
You no longer get
the cell cycle.
So this shows you mRNA is
important or necessary.
But you don't know
which mRNA, right?
One hypothesis might be that
you need the mRNA from M cyclin
in order to produce
cyclin every cell cycle.
And that was their hypothesis.
So what they did to test that
was to degrade all the mRNA,
inactivate the RNase, and
then add back the mRNA
to one gene, that
mitotic cyclin.
And what they saw when
they did that is they
restored the cell
cycle, suggesting
that this one mRNA, M cyclin,
is sufficient to restore
the oscillation of
the mitotic cycle.
OK, now, the last
experiment, which
I think is the most important,
shows you the mechanism
by which the cyclin is going.
Because they added-- and
instead of adding back
the wild-type
mitotic cyclin, they
added back a cyclin mutant that
was non-degraded all by this E3
ubiquitin ligase mechanism.
OK, so if they add back a cyclin
mutant and this mutant has
a deletion in the part of the
protein called the destruction
box--
and this is essentially
the part of the protein
that is recognized by the
E3 ubiquitin ligase, OK?
So the destruction box mutant
basically blocks this such
that cyclin is no
longer polyubiquitinated
and it can't be targeted
for proteolysis.
OK, and in this
case, what happens
is cyclin levels increase.
And then they stay high
and there's no cycle.
OK, so when you have this cyclin
mutant with the destruction
box deleted such that
it's non-degraded,
it's not degraded, you
get a cell cycle arrest.
And because this is M cyclin,
the cell arrests in mitosis.
You get a mitotic
arrest, a mitotic arrest.
OK, any questions
about this mechanism
of proteolytic degradation?
You all see how this--
yes, Malik?
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
cell [INAUDIBLE] what is it
physically doing?
ADAM MARTIN: What is
it physically doing?
It's basically stuck
with a mitotic spindle
and it's not segregating
the chromosomes.
Yeah, so it hasn't
gone through mitosis.
It's stuck in a specific
phase of mitosis.
In this case, it's
stuck in basically
a metaphase-like state.
One last point I want
to make about this
is that the mRNA for M
cyclin is just constant.
It's always present.
So this is constant.
You have constant mRNA.
CDK is constant.
It's the cyclin protein
that's going up and down.
And it's going up and down
because of this regulated
proteolysis.
OK, great.
On Wednesday, we'll
talk about stem cells
and we'll talk about guts.